[Music]
40 miles Northwest of Las Vegas since
the southern desert Correctional Center
where this man the 42 year old porfidio
Duarte Herrera was serving a life
sentence for murder he was convicted of
making a bomb and hiding it in a coffee
cup before it exploded and killed
another man outside the Luxor in 2007.
Tuesday our 8 news now investigators
were the first to reveal he escaped
hours later the Nevada Department of
Corrections said they became aware of
the Escape during a head count around 7
A.M an hour before they started
searching for him a U.S Marshal telling
our investigators he was armed and
dangerous that's until Governor Steve
sislak revealed he was actually missing
since the beginning of last weekend in a
statement saying he's now ordered the
ndoc to investigate the lapse in
security and information does this face
does this look familiar to you guys at
all it really does the nearest town
around 10 miles down the 95 now on high
alert many living here like Brittany
Mitchell and William Tillman learning
for the first time after we told them
there's so many kids around here that
just run around and play I mean there's
so many empty trailers from I mean
there's really no police presence out
here so it's a perfect place for him to
hide out however long he wants and
what's yet to be seen answers from the
ndoc about how he was able to escape
from this medium security facility
reporting near Indian Springs Ryan
mathie 8 News Now